Kanye West now yay was not the only
person wearing a white lives matter
t-shirt at the Paris Fashion Week his
friend and our friend Candice Owens was
standing right next to him
so we asked West what that whole thing
was like and here's what he told us
the more and more
I lean into God and work for God the
more wins God is going to bestow
on our team on Jesus gang
and for me to go out and just State an
obvious
an empathetic statement
in the middle of the most liberal
Central light to go that was like
Tiananmen Square or something like
with Candace Owens and we both wore the
shirt at the same time you know we got
some Jesus soldiers out here and people
say they're willing to die for it but we
live for it we're living for the battle
and what's the battle for life itself
our children
like Tiananmen Square yay West caniso
and standing there in front of the tank
which is international media
Candace Owens is the host of the podcast
Candace and she joins us tonight Candace
thanks so much for coming on so why did
you do that you did it together
um and what do you think of the response
why can't you do that
well I just want to say it was one of
the only weeks that I missed doing your
show and the only reason I would miss
doing your show talkers because I knew
that there was a cultural moment that
would be so significant as this was you
know I did it because Kanye called me
and he said that he needed me to be
there at the show he needed me to be a
part of the show and when he told me
what he had in mind and wearing these
t-shirts which by the way he told me the
day of I instantly understood what he
was trying to do and what the artistic
expression was what it offered was a
stunning commentary on the hypocrisy of
the society that we live in for years we
were told that black lives matter was
not an exclusionary phrase we were told
that it's just what we're saying we're
not trying to leave white people out
right we're just saying this because
this is a moment that black Americans
need to have in this country they were
totally fine when Asian lives matter
became a slogan as well Asians by the
way are doing better in this country
economically than white Americans
they're more successful in education as
well and they're more likely to get
credit cards as just one example and yet
despite all of that it was okay to say
lives matter we put on a t-shirt to
actually do something that was inclusive
to say actually white Americans you are
allowed to be a part of this too because
literally all lives matter and in fact
no lives have been mattering black
Americans are suffering as a result
because of black lives matter we know
that their neighborhoods have been
rioted in inner city communities and the
businesses are moving out of there the
results of black lives matter has been
white supremacy assuming that black
Americans were stupid and emotional and
would Loot and Riot their own
communities to fulfill a false narrative
about policing and so we got to say all
of that by wearing one t-shirt
it's just so interesting I mean if
you're triggered as they say by a shirt
like that no one who is mad about it
ever seemed to ask like why what if it
said Malaysian lives matter or you know
any anybody
you would a normal person would say well
of course all lives matter but like why
does this make them so mad it's weird
and dark it makes them so mad because
there is actually in this country a
hatred toward white people it is
undeniable the worst thing that you can
be in this country far from what they're
telling you I would say two things first
and foremost a black child in the womb
of its mother that is the most unsafe
place for a black child to be the second
thing is a white straight male right
because they perceive that as being too
normal right it's too normal for you to
be a white straight male you need to
make yourself somehow problematized by
saying that you're trans that you're
suffering that you're gay that you're
Hispanic that you have a biracial mother
something people are dying to say that
they're anything but being white and
again that is the commentary that we
offer by wearing these shirts you
actually cannot right now today on Tick
Tock you cannot use the hashtag White
lives matter because they say that it
inspires hatred and in fact Banning the
hashtag White lives matter is what
inspires hatred the saddest part of this
Tucker which I want to add is that after
wearing the shirt and getting back here
down in Tennessee I went to a farmer's
market and I had white people coming up
to me with tears in their eyes and I
told Kanye this occasionally right
saying thank you so much as if they're
the Forgotten people for just allowing
us to have our voices back they've been
sitting in silence completely sidelined
told that they are not allowed to be
American because there's a vicious
narrative around that somehow black
Americans are suffering from policing
and therefore White lives can't matter
they do it's obvious Kanye was correct
yeah I don't know why people put up with
it I mean no group no group no matter
what the like or what they believe
should put up with being singled out on
the basis of immutable characteristics
there should be zero tolerance for that
and yet there's enormous as you said
enforce tolerance of it it should stop
now I agree with that Candace Owens
thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight